They Keith.
You did, my friend.
How are you?
Good, good.
Yeah.
To restart the recording, or is it OK?
Let's stop it now, I guess.
Hey, Lee.
Really, morning.
Hey, gentlemen, how you doing?
Good, good, you tell us.
Doing good. How about you?
I'm good.
Keep him busy.
Are you also traveling for tomorrow's event, Lee?
Yeah, we'll be headed out shortly, I believe. So now just...
Ohh.
just getting some stuff wrapped up before we hit the road.
Thank you.
And I figured it went up here.
And...
We have got Torin, Hayre, Torin.
Hey, Toran.
Good afternoon, guys.
Hey, good afternoon. How are you doing?
Support.
I'm doing okay.
A lot of stuff on the go, a lot of stuff up in the air, trying to get stuff sorted for next week already for dispatch.
Kumar.
Nice.
Looks like Reza might be in another call. You check where Khattri is at.
Yeah.
The weirdest thing happened to me today. I lost the deck that I prepared an hour ago, in fact, 45 minutes ago. And I just went, you know, just supersonic speed and just recreated the whole thing. Hope I didn't miss out anything. How did it disappear? I mean, it was saved on my machine.
Ohh no.
Nice.
And it got, I mean, the name got changed. What? I'm just looking for everything, and I'm just all lost.
But yeah, finally I have a deck with me.
Yeah, just pinged our caddy.
Mm.
You said Reza is out or he's caught up with something else.
I just see he's it says he's in a call, so he's probably on with someone else right now.
Okay.
Alright, alright, no worries.
Yeah, I think he's on the or or escalation fleet.
Cool.
Here, Khattri.
Hello!
Good afternoon, Arkadi.
Yeah.
Sorry, hello. I request if we may make these biweekly, now that bench is no longer in the picture.
The calls by Vikram, sure, absolutely.
Thank you, thank you. Appreciate that.
No worries.
I hope that sounds like a good reasoning, Arkadi. Is that right? You're saying we're to a point where we don't need to check in every single week because the primary pain point of discussion is being shifted. Okay.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, I agree.
I just wanted to make sure that was, we have a good milestone rather than I want to speak to you guys last.
Yeah.
A...
Yes, yes, yes, sir. That's exactly what I was trying to convey. Yes, thank you.
No, no, no, thank you.
Mm.
Thank you, but that, that, that's perfectly fine. Uh, right, Keith, Keith, I mean, it's your meeting, so you can make that call, but if you, if you're comfortable, yeah.
Cool, cool, that works. All right, all right.
Awesome.
I will, okay, my screen is already shared. I'll jump right into it. The agenda for today will be the check-in, highlights, action tracker, forms analysis, voice of customer, we forward and recap. Very quickly, check-in. I think I'd like to start with Ronan's inclusion. How is the...
that being so far, Arkadi, since you were connected with him.
So far, so far so good. He is, he based on his existing experience, he was able to very quickly jump in and he already understood most of the systems involved. He is shadowing technicians right now in preparation for.
Kip.
Yeah.
starting to take tickets next week.
Oh, nice, nice. Perfect. So if anything is required from my side, just do let me know. He sits where I sit, so yeah, I'll just get hold of him real quick.
Of course.
Will do. Thank you.
Yes.
Cool. And just an FYI for you, Wanch is, I mean, I immediately after our call, I went on a call with Jaiswal and Wanch and that call went well as well. They clicked immediately. So yeah, hope this combination as in you with Ron and then him with Wanch, I hope that that works out.
Me too, me too. Thank you.
Anything else for any of the engineers for Jas, Jimmy, Paxton, how are they doing?
They're doing well. They're doing well.
No, Johal.
Nice, nice. What about the new folks like Baxton, for example?
His transition to the morning shift is going okay so far. Something needs to be explained, but he understands them now, which is not unexpected. He has never been on that crew before. But things are going well, yeah, with all of them so far.
Mhm.
Mm.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice. Good to hear that. All right, we'll quickly jump on to the ITBD recommended KPIs. I can skip this slide. We've already gone through this multiple times. Very quickly, highlights. Resource transition confirmed, replacement was confirmed, executed on July 2nd. That was a handover for lunch to Jess and Ron to you guys. The access piece is, like you said, you'll probably by next week you'll be on tickets. So looking forward to that.
It.
Team feedback remains positive. Das continues to perform well. Jimmy and Patson are progressing well with training. Jimmy's lower utilization was discussed last time, and this time I've noticed some good increase in his utilization. Apologies, power cut.
Lost my screen and we are back. Thank you. So yeah, his I see good improvements in his utilization and I'll show that to you guys in a bit.
That's OK, that's OK.
struggling with my cursor right now because...
It didn't take the power cut well, just a sec, please.
Right, I'm back. All right, engineer YCSAT reporting. We already connected with Jeremy, asked him to, right now the reports were being sent to Ash directly. I've requested if that could be sent out to me as well, a copy of it. So yeah, that piece is in place. Apart from that, performance dashboard feedback, update performance dashboard reviewed, feedback include new tickets assigned during this week, carry forward tickets and closed tickets, plus better visibility into ticket distribution and utilization.
That's something that we discussed the last time and Reza did inform that you guys are working on a dashboard wherein we could, you know, get instant access to such data. Any ET on that bit? Sorry if that was discussed the last time, the ETA bit and I missed out, but did you give us any ET on that piece?
It's still a work in progress even on our side, so even we don't have that yet, so we can't provide it yet for that reason.
Yeah.
Okay.
A.
Okay, I'm sure you guys are looking forward to it as well. That'll be a great view to, you know, in one stop place to see everything for all the engineers. So that's pretty, I'm pretty excited for that too. Action tracker, there's, there are a couple of things that are in progress, like Ronan's replacement, the orientation with JSL as well, that's.
That's something that we just discussed, Ron and access and provisioning, CCI with Jeremy, and operational alignment discussions ongoing. That's what we just talked about. Apart from that, we can jump on to the performance analysis. Again, for Jazz, Paxton, and Jimmy, we're not talking about Ron and right now, and neither are we talking about Wanch. We're just going to talk about these two individuals, and for the last two weeks, that's from June 22nd.
to July 3rd. For Jaspy, his billable utilization was 74% overall when I talk about average of both the weeks. For Jimmy, it's been 76%. Like I said, improvement in his utilization. Paxton is pretty much around that line, 64% in total. His utilization dipped a bit when it comes to utilization and also the tickets that he closed in the second week.
dipped a bit that that kind of dipped the utilization overall as well for the second week, so averaged to 64%. But if I talk about the number of tickets they've closed, JAST closed 36 tickets in total in the first week, out of which 19% of them were incidents, service requests 19% as well, MACDs 6%, and triage 56%.
Jimmy, he was able to close 28 tickets, 14 each in the last two weeks. 32% of them were incidents, 43% service requests, 21% MACDs, and 4% triage. Similarly for Pax, number of tickets closed overall, since he closed a good amount of tickets in the first week, so it's 38 tickets closed with 29% incidents.
50% service requests and 16% MAC days. Triage includes 5% of the total volume. Team summary overall, 102 tickets were closed, out of which 26% were incidents, 37% were service requests, 14% were MAC days, and 23% triages. Overall, team utilization is sitting at 71% billable, 149 hours in total in the last two weeks for all three engineers combined.
Two tickets close, but anything you'd like to add here?
I just for Paxton, that's a bit of expected since he's still restricted from Group A clients on their end. That should be changing hopefully soon, then his utilization will naturally go up.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Nice, nice. That'll help a lot. Thank you. Perfect.
If I talk about utilization only for JASP, like I said, 81.3% in the first week, 66.3% in the second, so average to around 76%. For both, for rather all three individuals, the working days for all three in the second week was four days, not five days. They were on one leave each for that particular week. So you'll see a dip in utilization, so 66.3% for JASP.
For Jimmy, first week, 75.3%, second week, 76.3%. Like I said last time, we discussed about his utilization this time, and we did share feedback with him as well. And he did take it well. It's pretty much visible. For Paxton, 64.7% in the first week and 64.4% in the second. And we just talked about that. Once he gets access to the relevant clients, he'll be able to, you know.
work on the closures and the utilization as well. If I look into the ticket closures for Jazz, 23 good tickets closed in the first week, 13 tickets in the second week, where he had lesser number of days that he worked on, 14 each for each week for Jimmy in the 1st and 2nd week, and Paxton 20 tickets in the first week. That was a pretty good number, 18 in the second week, and his average per day was 4.5.
tickets per day that he was working on rather closed in total. So yeah, 57 tickets closed in the first week and 45 tickets closed in the second week overall by all three engineers combined. Anything you'd like to add here? Any issues with the numbers that we look at?
Not issues, just want to add that, if possible, can we emphasize to the ITBD technicians that the phone calls are the number one priority, and that they shouldn't feel like, oh, a phone call is an extra ticket in my queue, because if it is an extra ticket in their queue, because...
Mhm.
Yeah.
It is, right? That means it is counted as a ticket in their queue, the phone call that they took, which means that triage will not assign them as many other tickets that are from an e-mail source instead, right? So it's not like they're going to be experiencing extra workload.
Not you.
Yeah.
Right.
It's just that that is the priority source for getting new tickets is the is that phone call, right? And we will balance out the workload in return for taking those phone calls. So it's not like an extra pile of work on them, right? So we try to explain this here. We're not sure it's really being.
Mm.
Yeah.
Mmh.
Absolutely.
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
Believed right, but that's how we extract instructor triage to balance the workload based on the on the phone calls that technicians take, right?
Okay.
Right, okay, okay, good. Have you noticed any sorts of call avoidance in the team Arkadi?
I...
Jasper is always fantastic on the phone calls. I just, I want to encourage Jimmy and Paxton to take phone calls. No data yet for Ronan for obvious reasons, because he hasn't started yet. Probably won't be until two weeks from now on the phone calls. Yeah.
Hmm, okay. Okay, fair enough.
Mhm.
Two weeks. Okay, okay. Got it. So yeah, Jimmy and Paxton, I'll gather that feedback. I'll definitely connect with them. And not that they're avoiding it, but yeah, I'll try and get, firstly, I have the data for their calls as well. I've added here on the deck. But yeah, so I'll definitely talk to them about this if, and I did notice that the number of calls that they've picked is lesser as compared to Jasp, and I really need to understand why.
Ohh, perfect. OK.
to be honest, that's on me as well. And if in case and the expectations that you've set about the balancing of the volume, so they don't have to worry about that piece as well. So that will be cascaded well on the meeting that I have with them today.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
No worries.
Right, resource transition from lunch to Ron and Pandey. This is something that I think it's no longer relevant since the access piece is already in place and he'll be active from next week onwards. And like you said, he'll be on calls from two weeks from now. But this is something that I captured the last time, so I can skip this slide. Ron and onboarding and execution, report enhancements and progress.
Mm.
Like you said, the report, even you guys don't have the access to that dashboard yet. And once of course you guys do, we'll be getting the access to the same. And of course, it'll be easier for us to plot the numbers here on the deck and we can talk about that in detail. And both of us will have the data ready beforehand, of course. So that's something that's going to help out on both the ends.
Utilization monitoring ongoing, Jimmy's utilization to be monitored over the coming weeks. Yes, we do see the improvements, but still he didn't not touch the 80% mark. That's the target that we maintain internally. So no admin work currently assigned from the client side. And we did notice that he did not use, but not much admin time, admin hours were added to his utilization this week. So.
something positive there. But yeah, we'll have constant eyes on Jimmy and Paxton when it comes to the utilization.
Sounds good.
Okay, we have no idea about the build it, right? Is anybody joining from build it from MSP?
Yeah.
Kip.
Oh yeah, we've heard, we've heard about this, yeah.
Sir.
We for the bugs, yeah, yeah.
Yes, it has already been.
It's been okay, cool, cool, cool, cool, and Habib is coming all night. Oh, yes, I did see that. Thank you. Thanks, Arab. Cool. Team GPS, that's seen grown ITBD product. That's probably been discussed in the past as well. I just skipped that. End of slides. Anything you'd like to add before?
Habib will be coming from I must pick up to you.
We wrap up.
Arkadi Torian.
No, I'm good. I already mentioned what I needed to mention from my side.
Cool, I'll take care of that call, please.
I'm good.
Just do you want to say I appreciate the new additions. Jimmy, Paxton, Ronan seem to be really good technicians, at least from my initial impression. So thank you for providing those assets to us. We really appreciate it.
Nice.
That's great to hear. I know we, I know we've had we've had ups and downs for the start of the relationship, but what I like to hear is us finding our footing, right? Because every group is different, every pod is different, even within an organization. So, Arkadi, Torin, thank you guys for your patience and your feedback throughout the process.
OK.
gets us to a point where we can find you those really solid candidates. And Sarbjeet, thank you for helping along the way too. I know you've been on all of these calls, even when I've and Arkadi tour and I couldn't I couldn't feel you're in stronger hands than having Keith here working with you now. I know.
Yeah.
This is a little newer, but he's incredible and we'll continue to check in about it.
Oh.
Sounds good.
Sounds good. I appreciate that, guys.
Thank you.
Kour.
Thank you so much, so...
And the only thing which I would like to add in to our in Arkadi though, we are moving the service calls to bi-weekly frequency. However, we all guys are just a text away. The Team Federation is open. Anything which is not going up to the mark, just let us know. We'll make sure that it's been taken care.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Ohh.
Sounds good.
Yeah, we can say, do we have a group chat for the pod? Because it's probably worth having one, just in case you ever need to drop something in. If, yeah, I don't think we had one prior, but let's get one built up. Keith, would you mind reheading that?
That's a good idea, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Absolutely, I'll do that. It's on me.
Okay.
Thank you so much. Brilliant. And Katie Torrin, if there's anyone else appropriate to add in, I don't know. I don't know how wide the scope you want to you want to make it. I'm happy to be in the in the space from our side, but you let us know.
Thank you.
It's on me, sure, sure.
I think from our end, just start caddy myself and Reza would probably be all we need from our end.
Great. Great. Excellent. Okay.
Yes.
Kip.
Awesome.
Sounds good. Alright, Aaron, have a great day. Thanks, guys.
Alright, awesome.
Thanks so much for your help, Khattri. Thanks, Karine.
You too. Thanks for joining. Take care.
Thanks, everybody. Talk to you later. Bye now.
Cheers.
Bye.